babe if i disappeared for five years
and you remarried and then i was found
would you divorce
your new wife for me
well if i loved someone else enough to
marry her i think it'd be pretty [ __ ]
up to divorce her
and if you're gone for five years i'm
assuming you're dead
so i don't know how to answer that
why would you even marry me right now
okay okay okay okay
okay
when they start
asking you questions like this
don't answer just like hey hey why what
what do we what do we what's this what
are you trying to achieve because
then they're gonna take personal the
hypothetical
hypothetical hypothetical
remember when i told you shut up
shut the [ __ ] up
and stop making a thing out of a thing
that is not a thing i have the feeling
that this
is exactly that she's going to make a
male thing a whole argument
about a thing that is not a thing and a
lot of you are like that and i'm like
stop stop
stop
but i want to know how you think we'll
cross that bridge when we'll get there
this is a trap trap it's a whole setup
because they're going to get pissed off
about you not answering
just you not answering
i definitely been there it's going to be
a problem now i'm just like i'm not
doing this
do not say i'm not doing this why
because this is stupid are you calling
me stupid
you're done it's like do you want it you
see how sometimes women want oh my god
it feels so good sometimes like
sometimes you go to my room i put some
music and i cry
i just want to cry i feel like sometimes
they just want to have arguments
what are you saying
and if you don't answer the question
it means you're being closed off you're
shutting the conversation down yeah be
vulnerable but that's not a conversation
if you have the capacity to marry
someone i don't after five years of me
being dead
if you're gone years i'm gonna have
five years not that long
i wouldn't remarry
that's your problem [ __ ]
that sounds like a you problem
if you wouldn't do it that's on you if
you guys are enjoying today's video make
sure you leave a like and a comment help
us out with that algorithm push the
video to everybody that's how you can do
it just smash it but it's not because
you wouldn't do it that he
just just imagine
none of us just imagine
[ __ ] you're dead
and you're mad
that someone is trying to be happy that
you love is trying to be happy again
so you think a sign of love is for
someone to stay miserable yeah after
you're not
hurt not injured
dead yep
because no that's not the question that
was not the scenario you proposed you
proposed if you had disappeared for five
years and i had remarried implying i met
somebody else who i loved enough to get
married to plus poss can you appreciate
she put him
in that marriage in the hypothetical
then she got married at him
for being married and her hypothetical
[ __ ]
you see why i got one of this
imagine
you're like yo
if i left a hundred dollars a table and
you stole it would you tell me i'm like
i don't know maybe not why would you
steal for me [ __ ] you're hypothetical
you may know the situation
i'm getting mad at you right now because
this
is book guys
let me talk to you for two seconds do
you have bad credit i know i said that
loud don't even worry i've been in that
position you know i was young i was 18 i
got myself a credit card made a bunch of
purchases that i couldn't pay blah blah
blah long story short i wish i had
something to help me build my credit
back up now i'm good and you can be good
too the extra card is not a credit card
it's a debit card you sign up to extra
you get yourself that debit card you
link it with your account and you make
purchases extra is going to link those
purchases to your credit bureau and
voila and on top of that you can get
redeemable points you're spending you're
getting points and you're helping
yourself build your credit back up
wonderful isn't it sign up today for
extra then build your credit back up
link is below or up or side i don't know
where he's gonna put it but go on the
link get your extra now it's [ __ ]
you're getting mad at me because i got
remarried
[ __ ] you proposed to me that i was my
mommy that's not me what do you propose
you told me i was it wasn't a
proposition
you said
here are the facts i am god in this
scenario i have created the world adam
and eve is you and your [ __ ]
now what happens now you basically
basically you're mad
at the create at the scenario you
created can you imagine a video game
developer being upset at the [ __ ]
scenario in his own [ __ ] video game
there was a woman who i was married to
who disappeared five years ago and
suddenly she shows up
i would expect you to get back together
with her because y'all never got
divorced in the first place you thought
she died and so if i marry you
and then she shows up all of a sudden
you expect me to divorce you that's
great that i didn't he put her in that
scenario
good
wow my dude he's good he's good well let
me rephrase no he's good
she's crazy
and he's marrying her
and now we're rewarding him for being
able to maneuver her crazy but that's
why they together because he knows he's
just he's unfaith he's just like this is
not going to hurt me i'm good i know
she's too comfortable in her crazy but
expect you to get back together with her
because y'all never got divorced in the
first place you thought she died and so
if i marry you and then she shows up all
of a sudden you expect me to divorce you
to go get back together yes that would
be the noble thing to do
he said [ __ ] you crazy yeah
you're nuts
and she poses should i divorce him
boo boo bear don't play with fire like
that because you're going to hand up you
she's going to end up with that's a
woman who thinks she got her man whipped
i know how whipped he is i mean she's
kind of attractive you know so i imagine
that he probably i don't know maybe
something that is about whip because
there's some girls that are like that
without whipping their [ __ ] they
just crazy but they can only be like
that with a [ __ ] who allows them
to be that crazy i ain't mad at that
i'm out of that i
i remember when um imagine a girl
getting mad at you while for something
that happened it's like that meme
when
when she wakes up from a dream and she
gets mad at you
for cheating on her in her dream yeah
yeah i remember cutting that [ __ ] up
real quick
i remember cutting that [ __ ] off [ __ ] no
we're not doing it but you know when i
see stuff like that
you know what i still you know i think
we're not doing this and i see these
women like hitting the guys i'm like
[ __ ] i wish you try me
give me your reasons give me a reason
but give me a reason though
that's crazy that's crazy
imagine a [ __ ] waking up for his
dream saying girl you cheated on me and
then he beats her that's crazy
whereas people are like that they get
mad they get heated they start yelling i
can't handle that that's too much for me
that's too much
what you said
the first time is what matters
you're making a thing that is not a
thing
you're making something a thing out of
some you're making a thing out of
something that is not a thing there you
go it's not a thing
shut the [ __ ] up
this car ride could have been music and
chilling no
you had to bring your oh here we go yo
here we go yo so what so what so what's
this scenario you had to bring the whole
scenario in this
no
shut up this happens way too often but
yeah stop no hypotheticals don't answer
them and ladies don't ask them
what is terrible that's stupid and then
you get mad for his answer